I'm back with Yunha
again from Locket and
we're going to be discussing design
principles and the user experience.
And specifically for Locket, what did
you know you needed to get right for
the user experience?
>> I think because it's the lock screen,
which is what you're so used to,
your default experience, so we're
basically changing that experience.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And
saying that this is a new lock screen.
This is a real estate swiping
over 150 times per day.
We need to make it very user-friendly.
And the goal of the lock screen is so
that you can unlock it so
that you can go to your home screen.
So we can't make it too
long of a process, either.
We want to make it simple.
Also, you don't know who you're going
to be with when you check your phone,
so the lock screen needs to be okay for
your kids to see.
Or for
you to be able to just wake up to it.
So it needs to be delightful as well.
So when we were building the content
on the lock screen which is currently
locked, if we were just using
the RSS feeds out there.
>> And just like slapping those
images on the lock screen,
it might not be delightful.
You might see a lot of blood or
there might be gun involved
on the lock screen.
So we had to start from a manual
place where we want to make sure
each lock screen that we're delivering,
to our user, is delightful and
something that you want to wake up to,
that you can see.
But at the same time, we also need to
deliver these real content, which is,
like, hey there's
an earthquake coming up, so
you can't be like a smily face, right.
So how do you walk that fine line.
Also on the lock screen
interaction side,
because you're unlocking your phone.
And you have some users that
are unlocking with the left hand
versus right hand.
You got to make sure that the button
here on the lock screen is something
that you can touch
from different angles.
>> Yeah.
>> I should be able to touch it.
And if this is like two below,
it's hard to do that with the one hand.
You have to hold it with both hands.
And also, android phones,
their fragmentation is crazy.
You have like your Nexus to the big
tablet, you have the small phones.
How do you make them all look okay,
on all of those devices?
>> Right.
>> So a lot of those
considerations are involved.
And also like the weather.
How do you make the weather
shown while in the clock?
People also want to customize their lock
screen, so I customize it using Locket.
>> Okay.
>> Where you can just upload
your own photo.
>> Mm-hm.
And, are there any other
sort of design principles?
We talked a little bit about
sort of knowing your customer,
when they're using the product.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Knowing that
maybe they might be around other people,
what sort of other design principles
went into building Locket?
Maybe in terms of like an aesthetic
viewpoint or something like that.
>> Mm-hm.
So when we were,
yeah a few things that we were thinking
about is like making it delightful.
Like is this something that you
want to see on your locked screen
every single time?
Also, is this something that you feel
comfortable sharing with your niece or
a kid that you have.
We have a few guidelines as in like,
we have our own Locket brand guidelines
where you're not allowed to use red on
the lock screen or blood,
something like that.
>> Yeah.
>> I can't really think of one well, but
we were always focusing
on delightfulness.
>> Yeah.
>> On the lock screen.
>> Great.